is this technology even remotely
possible because one of the things you
must have done when you heard these
claims and you heard that they were
watering it down you must have contacted
the people will make those machines
you must have contacted other industry
experts and there was this brewing like
Vera Knossos it's not possible that
there are notes can do what they do will
it ever be possible to prick your finger
is that like something that there the
other competitors are working on are
close to or is this so fantastical that
it you're laughed out of the room even
that there have been a lot of
researchers for the past 20 years in
academia industry who have been trying
to crack that nut namely running a bunch
of tests on just a tiny sample of blood
and the benefit of doing that versus
pulling blood is what well I mean it is
easier there a lot of people I mean if
you'd listened to Elizabeth Holmes
certainly she had a phobia of needles
that she inherited from her mother and
and if you heard her at the height of
her fame and her various interviews she
likened you know getting a blood draw
with the hypodermic needle to a medieval
torture mechanism
which is ridiculous i I don't know that
everyone feels that way but I thought
that was one of the most ridiculous
tests right I was like well that's cool
that you can do with the prick of blood
but right and I guess you could do it
more frequently which would also be cool
right you could but more if I've got
cancer or potentially or I'm sick like
not a big imposition to take a couple of
vials of blood well actually is it I
don't I just banged it like there are
certain parts of segments of the
population for whom it would be really
useful
newborns okay to be able to take a tiny
little drop from them okay that's legit
I've seen my newborn get blood drawn
it's pretty brutal to watch cancer
patients one of the a week yeah one of
the characters in the book was a Safeway
executive and Safeway and along with
Walgreens was one of thier enosis two
retail partners they were lucky that the
part their partnership with their nose
fell apart before their nose ever went
live with its tests and Safeway stores
but in the course of reporting the the
book I spoke to this woman who was a
high-ranking a
executive at its Safeway and who came to
have suspicions about the the accuracy
of the fairness technology and but she
had initially been really taken with the
potential of this technology because
when she had first met Elizabeth Holmes
her fought her husband had cancer and he
was getting stuck with needles
repeatedly in order to analyze his blood
so that they knew how to change his drug
regimen and and she thought that the
finger stick technology would have been
a godsend
but because Edison technology so is it
people been working on it for decades
they've come up with nothing basically
right and so maybe in another 20-30
years might be possible well I think
I've always wondered about Elizabeth is
she so deranged that she never saw that
this was impossible or is she so
deranged that she just thought she could
do it I know we're getting inside of her
own brain but you I spoke to a lot of
laboratory experts who explained to me
that even though there's been the advent
in the past 20 years of this field
called micro fluidics
which refers to the repurposing of the
micro fabrication techniques that were
pioneered by the computer chip industry
and that those those techniques have
been repurposed to move tiny fluids
through tiny channels even with micro
fluidics people have not been able to
figure out how to run hundreds of tests
right or even 50 tests right different
tests on a tiny blood sample and there
are several reasons for that and one of
them is that there are several big
classes of blood tests about a half
dozen of them and usually when you've
got your tiny sample and you use it to
run several tests from one class of
blood tests such as say immunoassays you
have no blood left for the other classes
of tests which require completely
different laboratory techniques and
instruments you just don't have enough
sample left which makes total sense the
other problem is that capillary blood
which refers to the blood that comes
from the tip of a finger is polluted
with tissue and cells and is just not a
pure
I secured a draw that you get from the
vein and and one test in particular no
one has been able to solve this test and
get it right for for blood prick from
the finger it's potassium and sure
enough
Thera nose encountered problems with the
potassium test and my source the former
lab director explained to me as early as
our first phone call that thier nose
would get potassium test results for
patients that were so high that they
only made sense if the patient's had
been dead except the patients were alive
any you talk about in the book the
Edison machines they were not working
they were taking blood samples from
potential investors and partners running
them into the back to put them on other
machines or just coming up with
fabricated results this is a sociopathic
behavior it's even a little bit more
complicated than that so the Edison
refers to the second generation of the
technology which was just an immunoassay
machine so it could only do one class of
blood tests and it didn't do them
reliably and the third generation of the
technology was called the mini lab and
that was supposed to be a box that did
it was a bigger box and it was supposed
to do more than just one class of blood
tests when they went live with the blood
tests in Walgreens stores in the fall of
2013 the mini lab was a prototype that
didn't work at all so what they did was
they dusted off the Edison and they used
that for a few immunoassays and then
they hacked the siemens machines to run
all the other tests and then to convince
investors that they really did have
groundbreaking new technology they would
stage these demos with not just
investors but board members even media
members where they would have the mini
lab prototype they would prick the
visiting VIPs finger they would put the
blood in a cartridge slot slot the
cartridge into the mini lab turn it on
you know would start whirring and then
they would say oh it's going to take a
little while why don't you come and
either visit the lab or over here go
meet with Elizabeth in her office and so
that the IP would leave the room
then a fairness employee would stop the
machine take the blood out and bring it
to the lab and and that little blood
sample would either get tested at the
bench by one of their laboratory
technicians